here now with more is texas senator ted
cruz you know senator um i don't think
we ever have to put boots on the ground
i think the way donald trump beat the
caliphate that grew under obama and
biden you know with pinpoint accuracy
and modern weaponry and technology our
military was pressing buttons in an
air-conditioned room in in tampa florida
we don't need that option you are a
a historian of ronald reagan ronald
reagan helped the freedom fighters the
contras in nicaragua with weapons he
helped the mujahideen defeat the soviet
union then soviet union with stinger
missiles i would like to think that we
would do the same thing here and not put
a single american boot on the ground
throughout this conflict ever do you
agree with that
sean i think you're exactly right that
that that we can and should help ukraine
win this war and defeat russia defeat
putin but we should not put american
service men and women in harm's way that
we should not put boots on the ground
it's the reason that that i oppose a
no-fly zone tomorrow morning we're going
to have president zielinski address a
joint session of congress uh remotely i
i think he may well ask for a no-fly
zone i understand why he wants that
and there have been some democrats some
republicans that have foolishly echoed
that call but but a no-fly zone would be
a mistake because that has american
pilots and american fighter jets engaged
in direct conflict with russian pilots
and russian fighter jets and and that is
an invitation to escalation an
invitation to world war three we don't
want to see that but that doesn't mean
that there's nothing we can do we can do
a great deal we can provide
lethal military aid as you said stingers
as you said javelins twice last year joe
biden halted military aid to ukraine in
december and in april of last year he
halted military aid to try to pressure
zelinski to give in to russia and and
critically
we should be providing jets joe biden
vetoed the polish migs for from going to
kiev that's what zelinski said when we
did a conference call with him just over
a week ago zelinski said his number one
priority was to get those migs those
jets so that ukrainian pilots could
defend themselves from russian pilots
you know you played that rather pitiful
video of nancy pelosi where she said
well gosh we should get them the migs
well nancy there's a real easy way to do
it pick up the phone and call joe
joe is the one stopping it joe biden is
the one stopping the migs and that
devastation we're seeing in ukraine is
the direct result of joe biden's
weakness his appeasement his surrender
to putin on nordstrom 2
and and tragically among the casualties
we're seeing are those heroic
fox reporters and and let me say my deep
condolences to the families of pierre
and sasha and our prayers are very much
with benjamin they are heroically being
on the ground reporting what's happening
and tragically that they paid the
ultimate price for that
you know they did
what is the rationale i i i understand
your arguments completely as it relates
to the no-fly zone but i don't
understand the resistance to arming you
know what differences make they've had
such success using the javelins and the
stingers
why this mysterious reluctance towards
the migs or any other fighter jets uh
what is joe afraid that vladimir is
going to get mad at him like he's afraid
that reporters will get mad that a staff
will get mad at him if he answers a
reporter's question
well unfortunately joe biden and kamala
harris in this administration they
believe that the way to deal with bad
guys the way to deal with our enemies is
through giving in is through
surrendering is through weaknesses
through appeasement we've seen this with
russia we've seen this with china we've
seen this with iran we've seen this with
venezuela that is their mo and and it's
been joe biden's mo for for 50 years is
he's been wrong on every foreign policy
question for five decades literally
since since when i was a toddler and joe
biden arrived at
in the senate he's been consistently
wrong and and so you look at right now
zielinski is saying
we need fighter jets and and i got to
tell you the senate foreign relations
committee
there is overwhelming even a bipartisan
consensus that we should provide those
fighter jets you know we had a recent
briefing where every democrat in the
room and every republican in the room
said provide the jets now
but but biden's view is somehow that
giving stingers and javelins is okay and
those stingers and javelins are right
now destroying russian tanks shooting
down russian planes killing russian
soldiers and he says that's okay
but somehow passing on the polish migs
which would do the same thing shut down
russian planes
that's an unnecessary escalation it's
just
biden is afraid
of of putin and not only should we be
passing on those migs so the ukrainian
pilots can use them we also ought to be
encouraging the other former soviet bloc
nations around ukraine to move
uh air defense systems into ukraine's
borders to be able to defend themselves
from russian jets and let me be clear
to get those polish migs to ukraine we
should not have american pilots fly them
rather we should do the same thing that
the plan was in poland which is to have
ukrainian pilots come and get them and
fly them back and then if they engage
with combats with the russians well
they're in the middle of an active war
that's how we we defeat them but not
only that we combine them what boris
johnson just said in the clip you played
that was really important we combined
that
with under cutting putin's revenue
stream by taking away his oil and gas
customers and we do that by unleashing
american production allowing
the super power the energy superpower
that is america to produce oil to
produce gas
joe biden has six pending applications
to export liquid natural gas he ought to
prove every one of them tomorrow so we
can take away putin's customers
nothing will undercut his strength more
nothing will cause the old kgb thugs and
the oligarchs to rise up against him
more and nothing will more weaken
putin's ability to wage war in ukraine
than taking away his revenue by stepping
in and fulfilling europe's energy needs
you know senator crimea was annexed when
when joe biden was vice president obama
president the caliphate it grew out
completely
while joe was vice president and obama
was president nothing happened when
donald trump was president and here we
go again now
it seems that putin's taking over the
coal country i'm not even convinced
senator and this is not a joke i'm just
not i am not convinced joe biden
knows that today is tuesday obviously we
have kamala harris when she explained
the situation what's going on in europe
well ukraine is a country in europe and
it's next to another country in europe
and that country's called russia and
russia's bad and they invaded i'm like
okay
and it seems like she didn't know that
ukraine was not part of nato
and then i just played a tape of the
third in line for the presidency which
would be the speaker of the house nancy
pelosi
um and let's just point out that she
seems to be struggling also the world is
watching our three top leaders senator
and i think they see nothing but a
vulnerability and weakness in america's
leaders i think i'll take the guy with
the mean tweets back
that had strength
look sean what you're saying is is
tragically true and what's particularly
galling is is these guys spent four
years during the trump presidency saying
these guys don't know what they're doing
and now the adults are back in charge
that's what they claim and and you know
today i was meeting in my office with
with a biden nominee to be an ambassador
and that nominee she said you know i
asked her what do you think of the biden
foreign policy this last year and she
said oh it's great it's really working
well i said really like can you give me
one example she says well ukraine we
produced enormous international
consensus i'm like you got to be
freaking kidding me we have the most
significant war in europe since world
war ii and you point to ukraine as an
example of these guys success my god
this was a disaster they caused russia
invaded ukraine because of biden's
weakness because of his withdrawal from
afghanistan because of his waving
sanctions on nordstream 2 and every
single enemy of america is stronger is
emboldened the chances of the next shoe
dropping of china invading taiwan are
growing by the day because they see
biden's weakness and right now biden's
emissaries
are
in
venezuela begging maduro to sell us oil
and are in vienna trying to beg the
ayatollah and iran to sell us oil they
want every enemy of america to get rich
to make billions to use to kill
americans and the one people they don't
want to actually sell oil and gas are
americans that produce american jobs it
is literally if you sat down and said
every enemy of america let's help them
let's benefit them every friend of
america let's alienate them let's
undercut them let's hurt them
sean you would not devise a different
foreign policy than the one biden and
kamala put in place
this is not a country that i recognize
right now it is not the united states
that is strong that is leading the world
and we see uh the consequences of no
strength senator cruz we thank you as
always hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else